all right so we're about to head to the
north shore today because we just love
that area but we're in a uh explorative
mindset so anything that we see off the
side of the road that catches our eye
we're gonna pull over and we saw this
sign
right there see that it says
local honey
and i saw the local chocolate
and i'm like
i better try some local honey local
chocolate and i love stands like this
because it makes me feel like it's like
a cuny family business and they got a
little stand over there so i'm gonna go
check it out
no i saw some loco chocolate
[Music]
wow that was not the response i thought
i was gonna get i thought i was gonna be
like
chocolate hey monkey i saw some locals
chocolate
there we go
all right
here's hello
this is a cool stand we got
we got honey for sale
and we got cacao
[Music]
wow look at that that's a honeycomb dude
look at all these bees and honey try to
get their honey oh
oh that's a big jar
[Music]
can we just uh like eat these like i can
just get a teaspoon and just
the honey yeah yeah oh that's awesome
yeah that's cool
can we get some honey and some chocolate
yeah
so she's saying that back there behind
those little trees that you see yeah
they have over 200
uh
that's so cool super cool hey there's
200 beehives over there mister
[Music]
and over here we got beeswax too
i don't know what these are for to be
honest we like soap
oh these bees are so friendly
hey mr b
that's a chocolate bar
all day the fresh ones are on the cooler
what's that bottle is that like that's
chocolate perfume you can spray it if
you like it
it's crazy okay did you place them on my
wrist on your wrist yeah
come here taika
oh it smells like chocolate smells like
your cocoa butter oh your favorite
all right so we got two of them
since they are cork sealed
we'll wait till we get to the beach then
we'll pop it open because i don't want
it to like pour all over the place and
since it's a tropical place the minute
you pop these guys open she was saying
that ants bees they all come and swarm
so i don't want to pop it open over here
and then just have like a whole flock of
bees it's a flock of bees a swarm of
bees swarm a swarm
a bee is following us all over the place
so i love the packaging a group a gaggle
a gang
a crew a murder
a murderer isn't that a murder murder of
geese so what is it crows oh murder of
crows
where did tycoon go taika uh-oh we lost
them
where did you go mister
taika
[Music]
aha
taika there he is
when you're driving through this side of
town
it's just so
peaceful
it's literally the opposite of waikiki
so we passed by
this
little cute shop
and look at everything they got here
we could get
the sauna
massage
thrift shop scoop of paradise jewelry
cafe
car rental
juice bar
mexican food everything
and they got breakfast
lunch and dinner
and this is what it looks like on the
inside
walk in
all these shops this one's closed
upstairs
oh what that's so cool
you can go all the way up here
grandma gotta work for grandma
the bulls
but they're closed on tuesdays oh
they're closed on tuesdays yeah
so don't come around tuesday guys but
they got a cool oh they do have a cool
shop
oh yeah
yeah for grandma next time next time
well it's a cool shop though
okay that is one thing that i've been
learning more about hawaii
like hawaii time is real you'll go to
places and they randomly close on a
monday or a tuesday or they don't even
open until 3 p.m they're straight up on
island time
so a lot of places you should call
check on the open hours because if
you're from the city you're not going to
be used to it
what is cool though
is that last time we got snow puppies
from
and it was so good
that we have to get it again and it's
cool that it's on the way here
there we go
snow puffies oh puffies or puppies
oh there's no puffies people calling
them puppies the whole time
tell me about all this stuff monkey what
do you see
whoa
oh yeah that's the good stuff
snow puffy look at all of that
see all the good stuff
yep
it looks yummy huh
yep
you eat all of them whoa
it's a cool place all i got sandwiches
should we just buy our food for the
beach here
we got sandwiches and stuff too whatever
what is that
whoa that's a crazy way we're gonna do
that
[Music]
it's fine we'll look for bento boxes
okay
this place is really cozy though i love
mom and pop shops like this
where it's like yeah food
i would get that to be honest because it
looks good
but since it is our last day on the
island i want to get a big variety of
things so i'm gonna see if there's a
dental box place down the street or
something but you could get snow puppies
drinks
there's a microwave to even microwave
stuff they just got a puny little place
got a fan going on oh man it's so cute
they took the whole tray yeah
about to go to hale eva on the north
shore
we got food gas shops and peaches and
yes you pronounce the w with the v
look at this view
oh my goodness
look at that dude
see a monkey
isn't it beautiful it is beautiful
back in the cuny town again
i love seeing buildings like this bonsai
bowls
and then you got
surf shops
with cool stuff
the hawaii pride towels
oh we got a bridge coming up
is this the bridge where people jump off
of yeah that's so cool to die
to die dive i'm just kidding oh yeah
because right below us is the ocean
i think people are watching maybe that's
where they're going so slow
yeah there's a bridge people jump off
into the water they dive into it
there's some people right here oh they
don't look like divers though
because they'll literally climb to the
top right here
and they'll do a flippity flip
you have to yeah up and they jump
i love shops like this they're so cuny
reminds me of like the hawaiian knott's
berry farm
snoopy surf shop that's pretty cool
maui divers jewelry
matsumoto shave ice this place is famous
although i heard it's not the best but
it's still famous you want to check that
out
island vintage coffee
this is where clark little had his um
remember he had his like um
photos displayed oh yeah
yeah with all the cool turtles and short
break shots yeah uncle bows oh wow they
got a um hardware store here
oh wait no that's home depot is it
oh i forgot
you could actually live here it's like a
live live town it's not just a tourist
sounds a live live town that's dope
because you got your food lamps you got
supermarket you got home depot you got
your hardware you got actual banks dude
you got ace you got shave ice you didn't
hear that all these restaurants
what it's ace i know you said home depot
you didn't even say home depot you said
home people oh i'm sorry
spaghettini where oh you know that's
authentic what is that that's authentic
there's a market another market look at
that that's awesome
that's dope
this is an actual i didn't know north
shore was an actual town i just thought
it was like a tourist place it was an
actual town you could actually live in
which is super cool
there's these guys hey
we all know when it comes to the kwanz a
forever home
isn't really up for our bro
all right so i was looking on yelp for
some bomb places to eat at
and this place konos
had like a thousand reviews over a
thousand four and a half stars ah
there's a big old chicken
it's a big rooster
that's cuny
hey
good morning
look at that guy there's another big
chicken right here
milkshakes oh my goodness so anything
with glue pagan is what we're known for
okay so what are you guys known for a
little pig oh okay so it's a 12-hour
roast support
so yeah so breakfast and lunch all day
all the glamours are burritos they all
come with eggs potatoes and cheese
the chun's is probably the best seller
on the whole menu it's pork and bacon
added to it okay if you're looking more
towards lunch old school it's a sandwich
with a slaw pig barbecue sauce and
grilled onions
cut in half with chips on the sides uh
the sliders are the same thing as the
old scooters on a hawaiian soup right
instead
yeah they all sound good and then uh the
kids menu is over here if you want like
a quesadilla or a mini pork bomber or
something like that
i think i'm between the uh burrito or
the sliders they said hawaiian sweet
bread that sounds good too
all right look at all this delicious
food i got a bunch of
the chef's recommendations
actually i know he's not the chef but he
did have a lot of recommendations
guess which one i want to eat first this
one you fat ass how do you know it's
already melting too i can't believe you
ordered it this one because they said
that everyone gets it's the mud pie it's
coffee yeah but it's not gonna run away
oreo you're gonna eat it with this
that's such a weird combo dude
you didn't even order a regular drink
oh my god nam try it i like i want this
flavor in my mouth first i gotta do
dessert first it's a melting pot they
could get a pick up that sandwich that's
how it's so good it does i don't even
know which one this is but they're known
for their pork here is what he said yup
they're part oh oh dang it's freaking
liquid is doing its thing just dripping
wow
is that good
what are you serious
i like it
the bread is really crunchy soft on the
inside warm obviously
oh you didn't take a bite here we got to
get the get the number one review right
here go a little cagey it's called dude
okay oh that's a big bite that's okay
big boy pie tell them good job tell them
how you like the taste how do you like
it mister
this guy could be the honest review give
me the honest
double thumbs up
good job you never get those i know i
mean it's really good
all right this is the moment
this little man has been waiting for
the whole
car ride here this whole meal there you
go this thing's bigger than your head
dude
hey
i love you
all of a sudden
okay you wanna eat it okay i'm gonna eat
you're not gonna eat at me i'm just
kidding
is it everything you dreamed of
supposed to start picking out the
chocolate guys the whole thing your
hootie hooties
no it's not poop this is chocolatey
you ready for ours
snow puppies
one
for papa
damn i don't know that mouth could
unhinge that way
pure
bliss
i'm a snake
look at this super cool hawaiian store
got all kinds of stuff
seashell wind chimes bamboo
got ice cream to this side
sunglasses
hats to stay cool
and all kinds of
cool signs
little kahuna crossing
no
trespassing
shoes no shirt no skirt no problem i
like this one that's funny
so i'm getting two signs
i like this one diver
parking only because i'm a diver now and
uh all others will get the bends the
bends is when you get like nitrogen
poisoning and you start like
that so it's like an inside jump only
divers will get it which means no one
will get it
this one is a funny one no shoes no
shirt no skirt no problem get it pervert
yeah
look how little this guy's back is
he's cuny
look
bikini patoony
okay turn around
turn around monkey
monkey we gotta get you everywhere you
got that little baby skin hey come here
come on
no i'm just i'm not spraying it anymore
turn around look at me there you go
kids are like a straight-up octopus dude
they're just like all the time
checking out a new beach today still in
the north shore it's called three tables
and it's known because it looks like
three tabletops
in the ocean
water is just blue and turquoise as
before
love all the rocks over there extremely
gorgeous and beautiful
lots of cool rock formations here which
is awesome
because taika has been loving looking at
seashells and stuff so anytime there's
little crevices
it's a good place for this little dude
to find a seashell i got a bag like a
big shower from snail you did yes from
there from down there that's awesome
that's awesome
and for me
i like those rocks over the three tables
because around rocks is usually where
you find life
so i brought my full snorkel stuff i
brought my gopro stuff so i'm gonna dive
around there and it's cool because the
swim isn't too far this is from here to
there
whereas uh some of the really scenic
spots you gotta swim really really far
and you get tired but over here you
don't have to
you got a little tent set up like usual
and we have it facing the other way
because that's where the sun's coming
from this way so that way we get the
most shade so i like this area so much
that on our way back
hanging at the beach i was like we gotta
get a hella eva sign and i know exactly
which sign i want to get and this store
has it that one
did we say it we get one of these and we
get we're like grandma we found this i
know and monkey see how big these shells
are look at that
holy moly
that's bigger than your head
careful not to drop it okay don't drop
it
these are so awesome
what's awesome i was about to say sick
but awesome came out
it's awesome
whoa
look at this one hootie
look hoodie whoa this one's heavy look
it's bigger than your head
oh i think you keep saying that
i i honestly feel like we should buy
this whoa that was bigger than your head
we should have bought this
oh that's nice
there's all these cool signs
any of them catch your eye
crickets
oh cricket for like uh
you watch it on youtube
they play that in india or pakistan i
think you can't
really put on your pjs you crazy
this guy's a straight-up comedian i love
this guy so much
a big watermelon what are you talking
about
it's time for this guy to go to
bed it's time for this guy because it's
our last day here
what see
go
whoa that was cool
okay last one last flip and tell
everyone good night
good night